from roosterteeth the company that gave
us people pissing about in Halo that
somehow became ultra successful and
Monty Oum the guy they gave us sexy
girls fighting one-on-one sexy girls
fighting three-on-three sexy girls
fighting in a battle royale and finally
Samus vs Master Chief who both turned
out to be sexy girls fighting they give
you aa b wy or is it r WB well I can
never remember the right order the
series the promises sexy girls fighting
now color-coded yeah that pretty much
sums up my initial reaction to our W R B
Double R double mighty morphing Mahou
shoujo z' so I wasn't gonna do a video
about Ruby since it's much smaller in
scale than the stuff I'm used to talking
about
and I personally judge it differently
from the typical ad mate but because you
guys would not shut up about it I
thought I'd just give everyone my quick
stores clergy that don't know Ruby is a
new anime starred webseries done by
roosterteeth best known for their work
with red vs. blue and was created and
directed by Monty Oum who is best known
for his dead fancy series before he
joined roosterteeth the show is kind of
the first of its kind being an American
produced webseries with a very anime
style made by people who essentially
rose to fame by making silly stupid
internet fan videos [ __ ] that's gonna
lie wondering so it sits in the gray
area of whether this really counts as an
anime or not which people have been
arguing and arguing over and over about
and so I'd like to create my own new
category two classes in called honestly
who really gives up flying buck it's a
show that's been teased by roosterteeth
for many months now showing trailers
with the four main characters showcasing
what Monty does best girls plus fighting
Plus kick-ass mess there's not much I
can really say about a story since
there's only been two episodes out at
the time of this video but to summarize
they've created a world which some kind
of beasts are in them that some special
humans called huntresses fight using
some sort of power called dust not magic
dust one to hume has made it very clear
that this dusting is not magic and
really is its own thing
it's not magic guys there's a Sony
different saying shut up
now all we've seen so far is it set up
to the world and also our main character
that is just starting attendance to a
huntress training academy called
Hogwarts
I mean bacon I mean beacon beacon so far
it's kind of looking like a roosterteeth
version of soul eater and for the type
of world that is building up I doubt
they'll be able to explore everything
within just one season of this but it
definitely is an interesting world
they're in from what I've heard from the
soundtrack
well it's surprisingly really [ __ ]
good so far and actually kicks the arse
out of love animes soundtracks now while
managing to compliment the action
perfectly so I'm looking forward to
hearing the rest of the soundtrack one
of the biggest concerns I had going into
this was a voice acting since the acting
and dialogue we got from the trailers
felt very force or canned and sometimes
cringe-worthy is this girl
I don't know Miller but we should teach
her our lessons but have you seen the
first two episodes the voice acting has
improved a lot and while it's through a
bit below or warm you still at anime
dubs it's still acceptable but honestly
if you have problems with the voice
acting or you're just a debater then I'm
sure it won't be a problem to just
switch to subs cuz the original Japanese
version is always better than the
English dub haha
oh wait animation why is the whole thing
felt like one giant cut scene from a
Tales game if you've ever played one of
them with some little awkward moments
here and there like when Ruby appearing
Lea disintegrates cookies upon contact
with her mouth but I've always fine for
the type of production it is this of
course not talking about the action
scenes which let's be honest guys is the
reason we're bloody watching this show
if there's one thing I trust in monty
oum it's his fight scenes and
choreography because one they look
[ __ ] awesome and two they look
[ __ ] awesome the action feels like
what goes on in the head of a
daydreaming seven-year-old cuz even by
normal anime standards there's little
that can match the totally off-the-wall
and nearby impossible stunts that these
characters achieved when they're pulling
off what looks to be like a 247 hit
combo without so much as breaking a
sweat
it feels like a type of [ __ ] of
walls combos and actions you see while
playing Devil May Cry except it's even
better because of how [ __ ] the
awesome all the weapons are and I'm
pretty sure the creative process behind
making them boils down to taking a
pre-existing weapon putting a gun in it
followed by the phrase cuz why the [ __ ]
not just from what we've seen you have a
rapier that can use magic and shoot ice
and other [ __ ] cuz why the [ __ ] not a
red death scythe that doubles up as a
massive 50 cows light rifle because why
the [ __ ] not swords that can be shot and
gauntlets that fires shotgun bullets
because why the [ __ ] not and finally a
baseball bat that fires grenades and
also can be used as a bazooka so with
this in mind I suspect the weapon of the
final villain would be a lightsaber that
is also a gun that shoots more guns that
doubles up as a bazooka that can
transform into an Apache helicopter and
if that turns out not to be the case
well get on it Monty because why the
[ __ ] not now the reason I didn't want to
make this video in the first place was
because I wasn't sure how to judge a
show like this since it sits somewhere
between an actual professional project
and just an amateur project made by fans
and [ __ ] I use the word amateur very
lightly because while roosterteeth is a
production company and I'm sure there
are many talented people behind this
production it's still nothing compared
to the wealth knowledge and know-how
that say the newly formed studio trigger
has who has experience working on big
high budget and successful projects so
looking at it both ways this could
either be a really top-of-the-line
amateur project that [ __ ] kicks ass
or a really low budget professional
project that doesn't quite match up to
the standards that were used to but no
matter what I gave props to the team at
roosterteeth and Monty for putting this
off I could go on and mate pick but I
really don't want to because this is
obviously a passion project that is
being done by a small team a tight
schedule and a very low budget so they
should be proud for being able to pull
off such a feat to begin with this was
made by a fan of anime who obviously
wanted to make his own and we can't say
that we haven't thought about doing that
at least once and if he wants to make a
show about a group of multicolored
super-powered Barbie dolls fighting
monsters using impossibly impractical
weapons then we should just let him why
you ask
cuz why the [ __ ] not
hey guys get ok I hope you enjoyed that
reaction video now before you go I've
got a quick announcement to make
I'm gonna be attending Alcorn in
Leicester from the 5th of September to
the 8th of September so if you're in
England and you've ever want to see me
in person God knows why you'd want to do
that and come to alcohol next month on
the 5th of September to the 8th of
September if you're new to my videos
then you can find some of my other
reactions and reviews here and don't
forget you can follow me on Facebook and
Twitter in the description below if you
want to watch Ruby then you can watch it
here on youtube or on rooster teeth's
website anyway that's it for me and I
learn so remember if you wanna come see
me come see me at Alcor next month but
until then I'll see you all next time